allora oggi vi parlerò di alcune
situazioni in cui la matematica ci mette
in grado di vedere un nuovo di dietro un
apparente disordine apparente di soldi
ne può venire da situazioni
completamente caotica e noi non
riusciamo a riconoscere come essere
dotate di un certo ordine
invece spesso c'è una semplice regola
che le chele legge e questa regola può
essere più semplice di quello che sembra
le giocate per certi insiemi che si
chiamano frattali e questi insiemi sono
degli strani oggetti matematici come ad
esempio il cavolo romano allora questo
bel cavolo che ottimo da mangiare
specialmente a quest'ora che ora di
merenda è in realtà un oggetto
abbastanza sofisticato che gode di una
proprietà molto sorprendente questa
proprietà da si vede guardando per
esempio altri oggetti ai quali siamo più
abituati
per esempio se uno guarda il cavolo da
una scala di 10 metri cioè si mette a 10
metri di distanza non vede più i
dettagli lo idealizza con una piramide
vede praticamente una piramide allora
concentriamoci un attimo sulla piramide
avviciniamoci è uno dei lati con
l'occhio se ci avviciniamo noi non
vediamo più la piramide vediamo
ovviamente il lato della piramide cioè
vediamone superficie questa è una
proprietà che conosciamo sin da quando
eravamo piccoli cioè oggetti lo stesso
oggetto guardato a scale diverse cambia
la stessa cosa accade con un pallone di
calcio con una sfera 10 guardia 10 metri
e vede una sfera se lo guarda proprio da
vicino non vede più la sfera vede il
cosiddetto piano tangente se si mette su
questo punto blu e quello che noi è
quello che ci accade normalmente quando
camminiamo sulla terra per questo ci
sembra piatta la terra è più o meno una
sfera però noi siamo così piccoli che
sostanzialmente siamo un puntino e la
guardiamo da una distanza così piccola
che ci sembra piatta e noi camminiamo
sul piano tangente alla terra quindi
questo è il secondo oggetto che ha una
proprietà abbastanza nota guardato da
una scala sembra una cosa quella data da
un'altra scarsa invece un'altra cosa
se poi questo è un pallone da calcio e
vi mettete col microscopio elettronico
sul punti più blu non vede più neanche
la
una causa piatta vedete la scala atomica
quindi cambio scala cambia la forma
dell'oggetto adesso applichiamo la
stessa cosa al cavolo romano allora come
si diceva il capo loro mano se uno lo
guarda da lontano sempre una piramide
quindi anche se uno lo guarda da vicino
dovrebbe succedere la stessa cosa che ci
succede con una dinamica c'è uno guarda
la superficie se uno guarda la guarda da
vicino
che cosa fa guarda di nuovo il cavolo
romano quindi il cavolo romano quale
dato a due scale completamente diverse
diciamo 56 10 metri o 55 66 cm sembra la
stessa cosa e se prendiamo la lente
d'ingrandimento e quindi ingrandiamo di
nuovo per esempio su uno di questi punti
ingrandendo troviamo di nuovo il cavolo
romano quindi questa è una proprietà
completamente diversa da quella degli
altri due oggetti perché è un oggetto
che se voi lo guardate a scale
completamente diverse
sembra sempre la stessa cosa cioè
riproduce se stesso a scale diverse e
così si potrebbe andare certamente un
certo punto ci si fermava un evidente
idealizzazione matematica ci porta a
pensare che possono esistere oggetti che
guardati a tutte le scale sono sempre
uguali a se stessi se ci pensate una
cosa molto inusuale però in natura
questo non è l'unico caso in cui succede
questo per esempio la felce la felce è
fatta esattamente in questo modo
guardate la felce verde prendete il
ramoscello rosso e se lo è ingrandita e
sembra esattamente uguale alla fece
realtà
dopodiché prendete il modello giallo
della felce rossa ingrandita lo ed è
uguale a quelli precedenti e così si va
avanti e di questo è un secondo esempio
un altro esempio sono gli alberi gli
alberi sono strutture che come leve come
vedete sembrano strutture completamente
di sole di cate però quest'ordine nasce
dall applicazione a tutte le scale della
semplice regola del ripetersi uguale a
tutte le scale
come fate un albero una parte dal tronco
poi il tronco si dirama in due tre rami
ogni ramo si tira ma in altri rami
ammiriamo si dirà ma ancora e così si
parte quindi la regola è semplice prendi
una cosa e diramati aveva applicato a
tutte le scale che la cosa è molto
complesse e questo è esattamente per
esempio l'idealizzazione matematica di
un albero reale di realizzazione
matematica di un'alba europea
reale porta strutture matematiche che si
chiamano alberi sono molto usate
informatica per informazioni per fare
ricerche binarie per strutture aree dati
per esempio un albero genealogico
questo è esattamente quello che succede
con gli alberi e guardate voi questo è
un pezzo di albero
mettete la lente di ingrandimento e
trovate una cosa che è praticamente la
stessa cioè alla stessa struttura
ingrandite di nuovo è la stessa
struttura e così di a un certo punto ci
si ferma però l'idealizzazione
matematica cioè la struttura ad albero
può essere fatta in modo si può ripetere
infinite volte voi mettete la lente
d'ingrandimento e trovate la stessa cosa
vi mettete la lente di ingrandimento
rimettete la lente d'ingrandimento della
struttura si riproduce su infinite scale
quindi apparentemente dietro questo
disordine quello di un albero cioè in
realtà uno aldini è molto semplice
quello di ripetere una regola
semplicissima a tutte le scale questo
ripetersi infinito a tutte le scale da
globalmente l'idea di una struttura
disordinata che in realtà è retta da una
regola molto semplice quello appunto di
ripetere la stessa forma tutte le scale
quindi la regola è semplice ma la
ripetizione a unisca la crea una
struttura e apparentemente complessa più
complesso di quanto poi si possa pensare
esempio il polmone il polmone fa
esattamente la stessa cosa
il polmone se noi ingrandite fatto da
questi piccoli ramoscelli albero che a
loro volta sono fatti da piccoli
ruscelli caldo cioè la stessa c'è la
stessa regola di diramazione allora
esattamente il parallelo è evidente
perché queste sono naturalmente il
polmoni a un certo punto si ferma perché
ci sono gli alveoli che devono prendere
ossigeno ma il parallelo con l'albero è
assolutamente evidente perché c'è lo
stesso gioco di diramazioni continua
adesso uno si chiede come vedete questo
qui per esempio è la il paragone tra un
albero matematico cioè l'idealizzazione
di alla struttura ad albero che dà
origine a una sorta di polmone
artificiale matematico o meglio
artificioso e il polmone artificiale
meglio lasciarlo perdere e un polmone
reale come vedete l'informazione il tipo
di struttura logica è perfettamente la
stessa 1 a questo punto si chiede
perché la natura preferisce costruire
oggetti così complicati oppure fa un
polmone
in questo modo ricordiamoci che cosa
serve il polmone il polmone ci fa
arrivare l'ossigeno e piume lo si fa in
più e si prende di ossigeno meglio è
allora qual è l'area
quindi qual è l'idea l'idea è che la
superficie totale di tutti questi
ramoscelli deve essere molto ampia
se ne andate a misurare aveva un campo
da tennis 70 80 metri quadri quindi da
un lato tu hai bisogno di mettere una
enorme superficie dipende da un enorme
superficie perché più superficie metti
più ossigeno prendi però dall'altra
parte e polmone deve stare come viene il
busto quindi deve avere un volume
contenuto il modo che la natura ha
trovato di realizzare questa cosa è
questo effettuare infinite diramazioni a
ogni scala queste infinite diramazioni
alla unisca la aumentano la superficie
in modo idealmente infinito a un certo
punto ci si ferma però secondo va a
prendere un albero come di e matematico
può considerare che la cosa si ripete
all'infinito su ogni scala e quindi si
realizza l'idea di una superficie enorme
cioè quasi infinita in un volume
moderato cioè finito questo è un primo
esempio di oggetto che come vedremo di
prima un primo esempio di che ci fa
venire in testa che ci siano cose che
non vivono bene le dimensioni su ali
cioè 123 senza arrivare alla quarta la
quinta eccetera
però è chiaro che se voi prendete
l'idealizzazione matematica di questo
oggetto che è il polmone e che cosa
succede voi avete una superficie che è
quasi infinito e quindi è una cosa che
non vive bene in dimensioni e due perché
in dimensione due c'è un'aria un
quadrato quindi cose di superficie
finita però è comunque una superficie
quindi non vivere bene anche in
dimensioni e tre perché in dimensioni 3
non a volume una superficie quindi è
zero allora non può essere in dimensione
due non può essere dimensionali 3
scattano le dimensioni intermedie che
vedremo fra poco
un altro esempio per esempio le
fluttuazioni del prezzo di un dei delle
azioni delle stoxx delle commodities nei
nei mercati allora che cosa succede
questo qui è il per esempio non mi
ricordo forse credo sia il cotone questa
è la fluttuazione del prezzo a 13 anni
le commodity sono rosa di cui
investitori non professionisti
dovrebbero stare lontani perché hanno
oscillato ni molto molto anche come
vedete sono oscillazioni apparentemente
casuali e sconsiderata
uno pensa che se vai grandi e 6 su 13
anni ci sono queste oscillazioni riduce
il periodo oscillazioni più piccole la
risposta è no perché se si riduce a un
anno trova lo stesso tipo di
oscillazione cioè questo grafico che
vedete qui è quello grafico piccolo in
quel pezzo di grafico di 13 anni aveva
uno dice vabbè allora se questa è
l'oscillazione a un anno va a finire che
in un mese a scegliere a meno neanche
perché io un mese ci sono le stesse
oscillazioni tutte le scale e così in un
giorno e così via
cioè sostanzialmente le oscillazioni del
prezzo delle commodity sono di altri
titoli speculativi sono fortissime a
ogni scala 13 anni un anno un mese e una
settimana
questo perché perché ovviamente sono
regolati da gesti speculativi e lo
speculatore vende quando il prezzo è
alto comprano dei prezzi al basso quindi
è interessato a creare più oscillazioni
possibili perché più situazione ci sono
più oscilla più occasioni di guadagno ci
sono dello speculatore
però l'idea di riprodurre a tutte le
scale lo stesso oscillazione è un'idea
che ha portato al come penso alle
persone a usare i frattali questo di
alle fluttuazioni dei prezzi del mercato
e questa è una cosa abbastanza
interessante
un altro esempio lo abbiamo dalle coste
questo qui grafico diciamo di una costa
assomiglia molto a quello delle
situazioni per quanto è frastagliato qui
il discorso è che la stessa frastagliate
za si ripete a tutte le scale e qui ci
possiamo riagganciare a quello che
succedeva col polmoni avevamo una
superficie apparentemente infinita in un
volume finito allora facciamo
l'esperimento per esempio di misurare
quanto è lungo una costa presente una
cosa la gran bretagna
la cosa e la gran bretagna 1 che cosa fa
beh se la deve misurare cosa fa la
prossima con un poligono altamente
irregolare ma sempre un poligono perché
perché ogni lato lo può misurare e poi
la lunghezza totale fa la fa sommando le
le lunghezze dei laghi allora se uno usa
un'approssimazione molto abbiamo molto
rozza usa un poligono di 200 km fa
questa approssimazione si trova che più
o meno la costa è lunga 2400 km 1 dice
un altro arriva e dice no no questo non
va bene perché i 200 km sono troppo in
200 km può succedere di tutto usiamo
l'approssimazione a un passo più piccolo
100 km l'approssimazione è evidentemente
migliore perché ci sembra che questo
poligono segua l'oggetto originale
meglio di come lo seguiva quello
precedente
però la sorpresa è che la lunghezza è
cresciuta cioè da 100 km siamo arrivati
a 2.400 a 2.800 dal 2004 2008
anche questa approssimazione potrebbe
non bastare di allora cosa fate uno dice
vabbè da 100 km passo a 50 e fa un altro
approssimazione che adesso è molto
migliore perché ci sembra essere molto
più vicini alla figura originale ma
anche qui la lunghezza è cresciuta da
3.400 da 2800 è passato a 3.400 è in
realtà uno potrebbe andare avanti
potrebbe usare passi di 30 km 10 km un
chilometro 500 metri e più si riduce la
lunghezza cioè più aumenta la precisione
più si vede che la lunghezza che la
costa tende a aumentare indefinitamente
cioè quello che i matematici dicono va
più infinito allora questo è un secondo
esempio di una curva cioè la lunga e la
costa che sta in un'area finita perché
la gran bretagna per quanto possa essere
grande la mettete in un rettangolo e
l'area è quella lì però ogni volta che
la andate ad approssimare la lunghezza
cresce questa è la stessa cosa che
succedeva con il polmone il polmone
in realtà è una superficie
apparentemente infinita che stava un
volume finito quindi qui abbiamo una
cosa di dimensione che dovrebbe essere
uno cioè una lunghezza ma che è troppo
grande per essere di dimensioni 1 ma è
troppo piccola per essere di dimensioni
e due perché avevamo una cosa che era
troppo grande per sta in due dimensioni
perché la superficie quasi infinita e
quindi non poteva stare in due
dimensioni in un certo senso ma non
potrei passare anche inter perché ha
comunque una superficie la terza
dimensione manca una superficie sempre
volume 0
allora questi sono oggetti che vivono in
dimensioni intermedie che sono stati
inventati dai matematici più o meno in
centinaia di anni fa cioè un matematico
tedesco assieme alla felix outdoor che è
esattamente quel 98 anni fa pubblica un
articolo in cui definiva le dimensioni
intermedie per capire come si possa
definire e precisa e calcolare bene le
dimensioni intermedie
facciamo il giochetto di costruire una
costa artificiale la costa artificiale
sarà lunga molto molto molto lunga però
sarà meno disordinata della costa
naturale questa qui si chiama cui per
l'i phone con la cui i funk off è fatta
così
prendete un triangolo equilatero per
esempio di lato 1 quindi l'area siete
sicuri che qualsiasi cosa facciate è
limitata da quella del quadrato di lato
uno cioè uno su ogni lato costruite
altri piccoli lati e quindi adesso dal
triangolo siete passati a questa stella
adesso quanti triangoli vedete prima 1
ora vedete 123456 triangoli quindi
potete ripetere il giochetto su sei
triangoli al pezzo passo avete costruito
altri triangoli su ogni lato del
precedente precampo e poi che fate e poi
avete capito come funziona il gioco no
più triangoli si creano e piume potete
creare e così questa sarà il quarto
passo il quinto passo sarà questa sorta
di costa fra tale perché diventa tanto
frastagliata quanto più o meno è una
costa e poi si può fare il sesto ottavo
il decimo si può andare avanti come
capita all'infinito la figura diventa
enormemente complessa però la regola è
sempre semplice questa è la
caratteristica di tutti questi oggetti
oggetti complessi ma governati da una
regola semplice la complessità nasce
dall iterare la regola semplice nomi
scala e allora l'idea è che la curva
aveva lunghezza infinita perché perché
se io passo da qui a qui cosa faccia
vedete prima su questa lunghezza qui ora
non c'è più questa lunghezza qui ciò
questa più questa ciò questa più questa
quindi ogni passo la lunghezza aumenta
aumenta esattamente di quattro terzi con
di quanto era prima se moltiplicato i
quattro terzi che è un numero più grande
di uno per se stesso tante volte
quindi questo è un altro esempio
esattamente come la gran bretagna un
esempio artificiale di curva che stai
un'area finita ma a lunghezza infinita
infatti secondo la definizione data da
ausl la dimensione di out of fame nella
dimensione frattale è 1,26
normale quindi qui siamo ben oltre la
quarta nella quinta la sesta dimensione
come vedete non occorre andare con la
fantasia nelle quinta sesta ottava
dimensione personale cose sorprendenti
si sono addirittura le dimensioni
frazionarie un po inquietante se ci
pensate è così per esempio si può fare
un altro esempio il famoso tappeto di
isner pinsky il tappeto di surfisti è un
tappeto quadrato da cui si taglia via un
primo quadrato quello centrale cioè voi
prendete il tappeto di vendere ditelo
dividete in nove parti il quadratino
centrale motivate via quante ne
rimangono 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 cosa fate al
passo successivo da ognuno dei questi
quadrati tirate fuori quello centrale e
ottenete questo
e poi adesso cosa farete da ognuno dei
quadrati tirerete sempre fuori il lato
quello centrale che cosa succede ogni
volta che tirate fuori un pezzo nero
l'area diminuisce perché state
sottraendo all'infinito se procedete
all'infinito avete una figura canale a
zero perché si può dimostrare che
togliete tutta l'area
però ogni volta che è aumentata ogni
volta che togliete questo il bordeaux
cresce perché vedete prima il bordeaux
era uno per uno che fa uno adesso è uno
per uno più un terzo per un terzo c'è
più un nono e così via
quindi ogni volta l'area diminuisce e
quindi si tende a scendere da due
dimensioni in giù ma la lunghezza cresce
mi si parte da uno e si sale è in realtà
questo oggetto aveva dimensione 1,89 è
la dimensione frattale che l'oggetto
ritmo di otto fatto logaritmo di te
perché è troppo lungo che sta in una
dimensione quindi deve stare su ma è
troppo non ha abbastanza re per stare in
due dimensioni e quindi di restare giu
questi sono esempi di frattali come
vedete sono proprio andati dalla stessa
filosofia del cavolo è umano la
filosofia del cavolo romano e prendi il
cavolo riproduci di a ogni scala e
questa è la stessa cosa
poi ci sono fra tali molto più
complicati come nelle sanzioni insieme
di mandelbrot insieme di mandelbrot non
è un frattale che possa essere definito
facilmente con queste regole perché è
definito dall'insieme di convergenza di
certe dichiarazioni di funzioni
complesse indicami che non lo muove fa
area bob comunque a quello che vedete
quello che vedete è questa cosa che
sembra un cuore con questa con questa
pallina vicino e anche questo si
riproduce identicamente a se stesso in
particolare sul bordo a tutte le scale
facciamo un ingrandimento dell'insieme
di mandelbrot e vedete apparire tanti
altri insieme di mandelbrot facciamo un
altro ingrandimento e vedrete apparire
di nuovo tante altre insieme di
mandelbrot quindi si riproducono a ogni
scala e così si può andare avanti
veramente all'infinito se andate su
youtube
provate a digitare mandelbrot set vedete
degli ingrandimenti che vanno avanti per
30 minuti 40 minuti cinque minuti appare
sempre lo stesso insieme
va beh questo è diciamo più o meno una
serie di esempi che ti fanno capire
esattamente l'unica idea che oggi volevo
comunicare che è quella che alcune cose
possono sembrare disordinate ma lo sono
molto meno se lo capisce qual è la
regola che il gioco che li determina in
questo caso la stessa regola
semplicissimi avevo applicata a ogni
dimensione questo è uno dei casi in cui
la matematica può aiutare a capire le
cose della vita
poi ci si può spingere più in là la
matematica intra in tante cose
addirittura qualcuno vorrebbe applicarla
i sentimenti cosa in cui io non ho mai
creduto molto non nei sentimenti nella
matematica applicata ai sentimenti però
c'è la gente che ci prova per il momento
possiamo di sicuro dire che i frattali
non si applicano ai sentimenti per come
li conosciamo perché vedete se questo è
l'insieme di mandelbrot che sembra un
cuore un cuore è invece fatto così non
ha un blog dove è sbagliato chissa forse
magari un giorno si potrà inventare un
modello frattale per cui sul bordo del
cuore pari rango tanti altri piccoli
cuoricini che daranno l'idea di quanto
sono complessi tra i sentimenti questo
però non lo sappiamo
fare e qui direi che mi dice mi potrei
anche se le marce